[Music]
take a look at this painting by peter
brugel the elder it's a bunch of
illustrations depicting common sayings
think of it as a where's waldo for
popular expressions
whilst many of these are in dutch some
of them carry on over into english this
soldier is armed to the teeth
over here the world has turned upside
down
and finally there's always a bigger fish
we use expressions like these every day
but have you ever wondered where they
come from
for example why shouldn't we cry over
spilt milk and who's going around
killing two birds with one stone or
putting cats into bags turns out that
many of our most beloved sayings have
some intriguing and obscure origins some
of which are pretty dark did you know
that the phrase saved by the bell may
have risen out of fears of being buried
alive but i'm getting ahead of myself
without further ado let's explore the
origins of popular sayings and
expressions
don't cry over spilt milk
the meaning of this saying is not
particularly intuitive in plain english
it means that there's no point in
worrying about things that can't be
changed
who came up with this unusual
lactose-based idiom
well it's not quite certain but it was
first recorded in a book of english
proverbs in 1659 where it was written as
no weeping over shed milk
some had suggested that this phrase may
have come from old english folklore and
that it's all to do with fairies in
rural areas it is said that townsfolk
would leave out a glass of milk for
woodland sprites if any of the milk was
spilled it is said that the fairies
would still be able to drink it meaning
that it wasn't actually ever wasted
hence the phrase don't cry over spilt
milk
others have suggested a much more
grounded origin
you see milk spoils very quickly and so
spilling any on the floor means that it
already has been wasted it can't be
recovered so i guess there's no point in
worrying about it don't cry over spilt
milk
there is or not the message remains the
same what's done is done as lady macbeth
once said
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
from gala to granny smith this victorian
saying encourages people to eat more
fruit in order to avoid unwanted trips
to the doctor's office
the rime was first printed in a welsh
magazine from 1866 as
eat an apple on going to bed and you'll
keep the doctor from earning his bread
this has changed over the years
from an apple a day no doctor to pay
to
an apple a day sends the doctor away the
version now commonly used first appeared
in 1922
and seems to have stuck
nutritionalists would recommend to eat
more than just apples in your diet to
remain healthy
there's unfortunately no correlation
between the consumption of apples and
the proximity of physicians as the rhyme
would suggest
but interestingly there was a time when
the word apple was used to refer to any
kind of fruit
so perhaps the rhyme refers to eating
fruit in general and not just the red or
green hand fruit that we're familiar
with today
kill two birds with one stone
this popular phrase encapsulates the
idea of achieving two goals with one
action this saying may have come from
ancient china
in mandarin there's this phrase it
translates to one arrow double vultures
and carries the same idea as the english
one the expression is based on a
folktale about the legendary archery
skills of general zhang sun sheng
in an attempt to impress his soldiers he
shot a single arrow into the sky that
brought down two vultures if that wasn't
impressive enough he achieved this feat
whilst on horseback
the first occurrence of this phrase in
english is in the 1600s where it was
used by the philosopher thomas hobbs we
don't know how it crossed over into
english
thomas hobbes was also the first to
record the phrase the feather that broke
the horse's back although you'll
probably be familiar with the more
exotic equivalent the straw that broke
the camel's back
both expressions refer to when something
reaches a tipping point when a chain of
seemingly minor events finally
culminates into one big and sudden
reaction in this case at the expense of
a poor animal for a lot of these animal
related sayings they seem to be quite
aggressive in nature take beating a dead
horse or grabbing a bull by the horns of
all the animals it seems that someone
really had a problem with cats plenty of
ways to skin a cat letting the cat out
the bag or curiosity killed the cat and
so on it's perhaps reassuring to know
that cats are supposed to have nine
lives or so i've been told in any case
noticing how many common sayings depict
violence against animals the american
animal rights organization peter have
drafted some new animal friendly idioms
that you can try out for yourself
so instead of killing two birds with one
stone it's feeding two birds with one
scone instead of beating a dead horse
it's feeding a fed horse and if you
don't wish to grab a bull by the horns
then you may prefer to grab a rose by
its thorns or or maybe not whilst
inventive these animal friendly sayings
have not been unanimously accepted
we'll have to wait and see as to whether
it catches on
many idioms stem from the bible in fact
this entire book dedicated to them the
appropriately named book of proverbs
some of these require a bit of thinking
to figure out the meaning
a cheerful heart is good medicine but a
crushed spirit dries up the bones
in other words nobody likes a grouch
wine is a mocker and beer a brawler
whomever is led astray by them is not
wise
which is to say drink in moderation on
the other hand there are plenty of irish
german and czech proverbs that would say
otherwise
across the book of proverbs they're a
bunch of sayings that contradict one
another one such instance is whether to
listen to foolish people
one says do not answer a fool according
to his folly or you yourself will become
just like him but another says answer a
fool according to his folly or he will
be wise in his own eyes
which one is it bible anyway moving on
beyond the book of proverbs there's one
popular saying that i'm sure you've
already heard an eye for an eye it's the
idea that if you commit a crime your
punishment ought to match it
in this case
gouge out someone's eye and expect to
lose one for yourself you can find this
saying in the old testament among a
large list of other biblical laws
but this phrase didn't actually
originate from the bible
instead it may have been copied or even
plagiarized from a much older legal text
you see a very similar phrase can be
found in the babylonian code of
hammurabi
in which it is decreed that if a man
should blind the eye of another man they
shall blind his eye
the code of hammurabi was written in
1750 bce
so it predates the biblical laws by a
thousand or so years
in which case this saying may be the
oldest proverb that's still in use today
speaker of the devil there are some
phrases which sound biblical but aren't
particularly those to do with satan
speaker the devil is a phrase used when
someone who's been talked about
coincidentally appears in the room the
origin of this phrase goes back to an
old fear that it was dangerous to talk
about the devil even mentioning satan's
name like i'm doing now could cause him
to appear hence the original way of
putting it speaker the devil and he doth
appear
this superstition faded over time and
the expression became less and less
impactful
by the early 1800s it was seen as simply
unlucky by the end of the century it was
a saying used to discourage
eavesdropping
nowadays it's just part of everyday
conversation and no longer a way to
summon lucifer
at least i hope on a quick side note
speaker the devil and he doth appear has
a positive equivalent
talk of angels and hear the flutter of
their wings
you may already be aware from my other
videos that angels in the bible are not
so well angelic
in the old testament they are sometimes
depicted as floating wheels covered in
eyes
elsewhere as animal human hybrids again
coated in eyes from heads to toes
at the risk of being visited by either
perhaps it's best i move on
saved by the bell
let's continue to explore the idioms
with dark origins
starting with saved by the bell which is
used when a person is rescued by
something at the last moment aside from
being the namesake of a cheesy 80s
sitcom
some believe that it's to do with being
buried alive
in the 19th century there was a mass
panic over premature burial which is to
say the doctors would falsely pronounce
a sleeping person dead and they would be
buried only to wake up in their own
coffin
to reassure families inventors made a
so-called safety coffin a small string
was wired inside a coffin that was
attached to a bell on the surface if the
unfortunate person somehow woke they'd
be able to ring the bell and help would
swiftly arrive
hence
saved by the bell
this story however is not the only
proposed origin of the phrase
some believe that it has nothing to do
with premature burial at all but instead
came about from boxing slang
in a typical boxing match if you were
losing a bout and were about to go down
you would hope for the bell to ring the
mark to the end of the round you could
be saved by the bell
to prevent a knockout who knows maybe
this saying doesn't have a dark origin
after all that's more than to be said
for this next idiom
bite the bullet
although nowadays this expression is
about confronting difficult situations
in america during the civil war it had a
very different meaning
the term supposedly originated in field
hospitals where wounded soldiers were
taken to undergo amputations
in a time before anesthesia was widely
available soldiers had to clench their
teeth down on something to cope with the
pain of surgery often it was with
anything that was lying about in a
battlefield that was usually spare
ammunition
i suspect they'd be visiting the dentist
shortly after
it's not just common sayings many
nursery rhymes are believed to have dark
and disturbing origins as well if you'd
like to learn whether ringer roses is
about the plague as some believe then
consider watching my video on the dark
side of nursery rhymes
it goes without saying that there are
many expressions out there proverbs
idioms and sayings are a feature across
all languages and cultures they provide
a useful way to condense big ideas into
short and memorable sentences in english
in particular there are thousands of
proverbs perhaps helped by the fact that
so many people across the world speak
the language as a result many of our
popular sayings have these interesting
and obscure origins
but we've only managed to look at a
small handful
there's so much more of them to cover
if there are some popular sayings you
like to explored in a future video
do share them down below in the comments
but for now let's leave it there
as they say
all good things must come to an end
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching i really enjoyed
making this video and i hope that you
learned something new along the way the
channel recently passed 400 000
subscribers i just want to say thanks it
means so much that you watch my videos
and like my content and also welcome to
all the new subscribers out there
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe
a like and a comment also go a really
long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]